[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Eric Boiron je suis
chef de cuisine aux terrasses de
Clairefontaine aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter une recette d'automne avec des
œufs pochés au cèpes et aux girolles
avec un coulis d'agastache
[Musique]
pour commencer on va prendre une petite
casserole on va y mettre de l'eau
minérale
[Musique]
on va y mettre à ébullition dès que ça
commence à bouillir on va y mettre notre
œuf bien frais
l'oeuf et gaucher
correctement on va le mettre dans de
l'eau glacée pour arrêter la cuisson
je vais vous faire voir comment on fait
le pistou et on comprend un blender on
effeuille toute la gastache
[Musique]
on prend de la bonne huile d'olive on
mouille quasiment à niveau un niveau ça
veut dire au niveau des feuilles
une fois mixées
voilà le résultat
pour piquer l’œuf exactement comme le
pistou on met la gastache dans le
blender ensuite on met de l'eau minérale
comme ceci et comme le pistou
on mixe
voilà sur le petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'huile de pépin de raisin un peu de
beurre demi-sel
[Musique]
une fois qu'il est bien noisette lorsque
le beurre ne chante plus
on y met nos girolles nos cèpes
ensuite on va passer à la sauce on va
avoir besoin d'une pistou on a fait au
préalable
d'une casserole de la crème fermière
[Musique]
un petit jus de citron voilà tout
simplement on va prendre une seringue
et on va juste tirer un peu d'agastache
voilà
[Musique]
on va se mettre les champignons qu'on a
au préalable poêlé ensuite on va se
prendre l'oeuf qu'on a poché
et on va piquer l'oeuf à la gastache et
à l'eau minérale ensuite
notre petite sauce
au pistou la gastache
[Musique]
finir le plat la petite émulsion une
petite entrée d'automne
donc notre petite recette d'oeuf poché à
la gastache cèpes et girolle
ma petite astuce pour pocher l'oeuf
fermier
c'est d'avoir un oeuvre très très très
très très très frais
[Musique]